hey what's up guys my name is a chino
and welcome to episode 13 of network
chat programming so last time we took a
look at the receive method and how we
would receive packets of data and today
we're going to take a look at I guess
the counterpart of that and that is of
course sending data
how does sending data work okay so I did
mention last time that one of the things
that would be a I guess happening is
that the receive method wouldn't just be
implemented normally as it is here it
actually requires another counter part
and that is of course a thread because
we want to receive multiple well we
can't sorry we don't want to receive
multiple packets packets at once but we
do want to be able to receive packets
while doing other things in application
we don't want our whole application to
freeze while you know well actually um
how do I says we don't want our whole
application to freeze while we're
waiting for data to actually flow
through into our program so that's why
we need a weird we need to actually
implement a thread for that we the same
thing has to happen for sending okay we
want to be able to send on a different
thread not because we have to because
it's more efficient this way and because
it's actually it's just the way that we
do things because it um oh well it'll
become more apparent so the other reason
that we are we need a um we can't
implement thread straight in this
receive method is because um doesn't
even ever going to be one like receive
call happening at once okay we don't
want to be able to receive on multiple
occasions like the same data and stuff
that's a mess and also you can see that
this private is that this receive method
returns a string okay so we're actually
taking data from it whereas the send
method is more or less abstract right we
just say okay send this data I don't
care what happens with it just send it
yeah just send it whereas with the
receive method we actually want to be
able to store this data so we'll make a
new method here called send so private
avoid send and it's going to take one
per out one parameter and that is an
array of bytes okay so similarly how we
actually received an array of bytes here
we also want to send sorry we also want
to send an array of bytes okay so to do
that we spread a new thread ascending
thread
now the way that I want to do this is
I'm actually just going to create a
threat object at the at the top here so
private thread and I'll call it send
because it's going to be our sending
thread so private thread send now over
here we'll hit will hit up send equals
new thread and then we'll call it
something just because it's well just so
we can identify it in the debug in
debugging in case something goes wrong
so new thread sandal called San and and
of course inside thread here we need to
implement a method called run as you all
know well you should know again I might
do an in-depth on thread and make sure
we start the thread of course
okay so thread don't start all righty
awesome
so now I actually sorry we can't do that
here because of course we actually did
make an object out of a called send so
send us done okay cool so now that we've
done that we want to actually convert
this byte of data this byte array of
data into an actual data gram packet
okay so here we received a Datagram
packet now we're sending a data gram
packet this stuff is pretty pretty
simple so Datagram packet packet equals
now our constructor here is going to be
a bit different than it was over here
here all we did was we received data
well or more or less we we applied the
data of the received packet into our
data array here byte array and of course
we received a you know a maximum of 1024
bytes of data so one kilobyte of data
here now over here we need a few more
arguments again remember when we're
receiving we already know what port were
receiving out we know all that stuff and
the reason we know that is because we've
created a Datagram socket with the port
here okay and we don't care what the
address is we're just receiving but if
we're sending we need to be able to send
to a specific destination okay so think
of it as this way right let's just say
um let's say you're receiving mail right
you don't really need to know anything
about that to receive you don't even
know anything about anything really to
receive mail right the person who sent
the mail does have to know of course but
you just said at your hair you sit at
your house and you receive mail however
if you want to send mail or if you want
to send a reply or whatever if you want
to
sendmail you you can't just no nothing
you actually have to know the location
of where you want to send that mail to
okay so the same thing happens over here
we can send our data which is this byte
array over here we'll send you no data
dot length the same thing as we did here
so that we send the the data in its
entirety here but we also need an
address as to where we want to send it
to okay so we need some kind of address
and I think we've got a I P over here
now when we connect to a server in this
login window and I'll quickly just
comment this line out so that I can run
the application and show you guys when
we connect into this login screen here
this IP address right this is going to
be the IP address of the server IP okay
so it's going to be the server IP and
the port is going to be well whatever
port the server is running on so we just
enter a name to distinguish ourselves on
the server then we enter the server that
the server's IP address and the server's
port okay that being said we need to
enter those data those fields in now so
we've entered them into the into the
login form of course we've logged in and
now we want to basically you know we've
set them here to be global variables by
a or class from my class rebels global
area called them even though they're in
the global in this class but we've made
a bed variables here let's say port and
address now they're strings at the
moment and I believe we are K and IP is
our i net address okay which is our
official IP address so we'll simply send
this to IP and port okay and that's
literally it
okay now in order for this to work data
has to be marked as final okay so go
ahead and do that I'm not gonna bother
explaining why that needs to happen but
it does okay and the reason we'll
roughly the reason is because this is
actually an anonymous in a class okay
that's essentially why to basically
prevent stuff like um concurrency issues
between these two different inner and
outer classes but anyway I'm going to
to that too much or you need nose and it
does have to be final now now that we've
actually created the packet to scent we
should sand it okay
so we'll just type in a packet here I'll
sorry socket dot send and then the
packet that we want to send okay
so Socrates of course referring to our
Datagram socket which of course is our
remember connection to the network and
then we're simply sending the packet and
of course the packet contains details as
to where it is sent because if you've
done networking or something you know
that of course the header of the packet
of course contains the IP address the
destination IP address and the
destination port after which of course
the router or whatever you're using
converts that into stuff like MAC
addresses and sends it around the
network now this throws a and IO
exception so you have to make sure you
handle then I'll just hit surround by
troy's surround with try cache because
I'm going to type it out but that's what
it will do okay
so like we're catching and possible i/o
exception here and that is it okay
that's actually the end of this send
method so you might be able to see why
I'm saying that it's a lot easier than
receive because really it's just is
really clear where we're sending it to
okay we're making a packet we're filling
it with data here we're giving it an
address of where we want to send that
data to and then we're sending it yeah
pretty simple stuff whereas with
receiving the thing that might confuse
people I imagine would be like like
we're receiving okay we're receiving
data but how do we know we're like I
don't know what port reserved it from
how do we know what address tourism from
of course you have to realize that the
address we don't need to know at all
like who cares we're just listening for
what it's listening for any packets of
data on a port the port we do need to
know of course and that is specified
when we create the actual diagram socket
okay so every socket of course has its
own individual port now this is pretty
much it
okay that's the to receiving the sender
method next time we're going to take a
look at creating a really quick server
and then trying to send data back and
forth and then we'll move on to blending
it in with GUI and adding them other
things that that actually take this to a
whole new level and that's not just
sending messages but sending things like
connections you know basically a
dad other data so not messages of like
you know so-and-so is connected or I've
lost connection to the server or stuff
like that
but thanks for watching this episode of
networks a programming if you did
enjoyed please hit the like button and I
will see you guys next time goodbye